hey guys P here this will be my Q&A for
Twin Peaks season 3 part 4 the questions
came from my recap and review so if you
haven't seen that you should check it
out I'll put a link here at the top so
the first question is does the weird
family photo and wally suave indicate
that he might be dick tremaine's Sun
rather than Andes um that's clearly a
possibility based on what we know from
the original run but I don't think that
that's really an important part of the
story as it is now so I'd say yeah it's
possible but I don't think it's likely
that they're going to go down that road
but you never know I mentioned in that
recap that there's a theory going around
that possibly Wally died young and the
family's been kind of stuck especially
Lucy and I think that's equally is
likely is that there's a dict remaining
side story here we know that the actor
who played dick Tremaine was not recast
or at least he's not in the cast list so
I kind of doubt they're going in that
direction next question was about the
four total FBI agents who disappeared
and it asks will chat Desmond Philip
Jeffries a Windom Earle resurfaced in
part three or season three here
well when the Merrill seems to have been
destroyed like at the end of season two
he you know his head exploded in flames
I think that was likely you know his
soul being destroyed I don't think he
still exists in the Red Room or anywhere
else we know his character wasn't
brought back or the actor who played his
character wasn't brought back David
Bowie also passed away and there's no
indication that he filmed any scenes and
I don't think they would replace him so
we do have mention of Jeffries already
in the you know in the series but I
don't think that we're going to see some
other actor step in to take his place
David Bowie's place in chat Desmond's is
just really a complete mystery if you're
not familiar with fire walk with me and
you know what went into making that the
FBI agent you know in Deer meadow was
supposed to be just agent Cooper the
comic Lockland at the time didn't want
to take such a larger role in the movie
so the whole chat Desmond thing was kind
of a last-minute addition to the story
now he did disappear in a way that would
seem like it would make him the most
likely to still be out there part of
something that's going on related to the
lodges but at the same time we haven't
read anything about Chris Isaak's
reprising his role so I think that that
story just sort of ends in a mysterious
question mark when he touches the ring
when did evil coop go off the radar or
in other words when did he leave town
well Bobby Briggs answered that for us
when he was talking to Frank Truman and
Hawk in the conference room in the last
episode Bobby says that his mother told
him that Cooper had come by to visit his
father just before he died and the story
there is that his father died at
listening post alpha you know his
station in the mountain the day after
that happened so basically we saw Cooper
come back with Bob showing up in the
mirror and he basically went straight to
see major Briggs either that day or the
next day or whatever and then Briggs
supposedly died in a fire and agent
Cooper disappeared and Hawk mentions
that no one's seen or heard of him since
that exact time so yeah basically 25
years ago evil coupe went off the radar
next question was do we think this was
the first time he peed in 25 years of
course they're talking about the scene
where Doug Lee coupe has an intense
bathroom visit and yeah I don't know
that guarantee that he hadn't gone in 25
years but he definitely hadn't gone
since he came back to the real world
obviously he doesn't really know how to
do anything at this point and you know
the he wouldn't have likely eaten unless
they fed him or gone to the bathroom
until someone showed him how to do it as
far as what happened whenever he was on
the other side I mean I hope we learned
a lot more about that but we might never
get more info the whole lodge thing with
the Red Room or the waiting room is
really confusing because you know
sometimes people consider that to be the
black law other times people think that
it is just the space in between which is
you know you got the white and black on
the floor I think there's a good
possibility that when we saw him with
the giant in the beginning of the first
episode that that may have been in the
white lodge but there's really just no
way to know so do they pee in the lodges
I don't know but you know it's a funny
question anyways next question was do
you think Shelly James Sarah Palmer and
so on bigad will play a big role in the
rest of the season or will they really
just be short cameos like we've seen so
far I actually do think that they will
play a big part part of that is because
it's based off of you know the original
series and there are quite a few of them
they brought back but also you know
there was a little bit of rewriting of
canon or history whatever you want to
say in the secret history of Twin Peaks
and a lot of the characters we know are
back had some backstory provided for
them now that's not guaranteed because
they also provide a backstory for Josie
and Josie is not back so I really can't
say for sure but I do think that at
least some things are going to happen in
the town of Twin Peaks and whenever that
gets there like the story gets there
then you know there will be some
resemblance of what season 1 and 2 were
all about we've also seen quite a bit of
pre you know pre stuff before the season
came out through social media posts that
people made maich an emic posted photos
of her and the double our attire and
things like that so yeah I think
there'll be a lot more I mean we still
have 14 hours to go so it's not time to
panic about not seeing you know the
original kind of look and feel of the
city you coming back the next question
was is episode 5 available or do we have
to wait two weeks so yeah this is kind
of outdated I guess but I just wanted to
clear up what I know about the future of
the episode release they released four
all at once two on regular show time as
you know it was a two-hour premiere and
then the other two were available in the
streaming service as a special deal for
subscribers as far as I know from here
on out we get one episode every week on
Sunday nights at 9:00 I look through the
show time schedule on the website couple
weeks out and that's the way it appears
to be I'm not going to claim to I've
looked at every week from now until the
end of the series I think I may have
something that there's a two-hour finale
but again basically we're into a regular
TV schedule now there's no more special
events or anything for subscribers as
far as I know that's fine with me you
know I like to have a week in between
episodes to do what I do and it really
kind of built the anticipation I'm
actually even though I've you know been
used a lot of shows over the years I'm
really not a fan of how certain series
all come out at once it's fun to you
know have a week to talk about it with
your friends and think about what's
going to happen and that's just the way
that I see it there were a lot of
comments about you know I said I thought
maybe Diane Diana was the one who came
to mind whenever they said they wanted
to have someone else
check out coop Albert and Cole that is
it was a lot of comments you know the
other popular theory that's out there
and was pretty much the first theory
that I saw was that it's actually Sarah
Palmer who they want to have C coupe the
idea behind that is is that she was able
to see Bob and perhaps you know they
want to use that ability see somewhat
psychic I guess you could say or she has
you know some kind of special talent
here in that case as I was reading
through there's other ideas to that it
might be Audrey I think that's the least
likely based on the story in the back I
mean she is yeah obviously one of the
big female leads in the series and as
she will be back but I don't really know
how she fits into anything related to
agent Cooper except for she used to have
a crush on him when she was a young girl
others have said Annie Blackburn and
it's sort of the same thing we know how
the Grahams not coming back of course
they could have changed her character
you know laura dern is rumored to play
Diane she may actually be playing Annie
Blackburn and they might just cut
Heather Graham out I don't really know
about any of that but it occurred to me
when I was reading all these questions
today especially in light of the fact
that that it that someone picked out the
idea that he says the first very
backwards you know evil coupe dozen in
the in the prison interview I think from
that on some level Gordon already knows
it's not Cooper and you know so I was
thinking what about if it's just it has
become a blue rose case at this point
and the person that they want to check
out Cooper isn't
really for the reason of figuring out if
he's possessed or not but you know as a
part of the investigation so I think
that actually goes back a little bit
towards it being die-in as well because
she's worked in the FBI she you know she
was confided confided in by Cooper when
you know he was having strange dreams
and things like that but you know it
could be anybody all those people could
work in the story if it's presented the
right way so I'm not I'm not for
anything one way or the other I just
think that the name Diane came to mind
at first whenever I watched that team
Sarah Palmer would be fine for the
reasons that people are listing and of
course if it is Amy or Audrey I have
confidence in the show that they'll do
it in a good way so I don't think it'll
be you know detrimental to anything else
all right so that's about it I will be
putting out my episode 5 recap and
review tomorrow as soon as the episode
airs
well not as soon as because it takes
quite a long time to make them but you
know after I watch it and I hope to see
you guys and get more questions in that
one and I'll do a Q&A later in the week
should be a little bit easier to follow
a schedule now that we have one per week
so I'll probably do you know recap and
review right away a couple related
Theory videos or bonus videos whatever
you want to call them during the week
and the Q&A will come before the weekend
so that you know we can all get on the
same page please subscribe to my channel
like the video if you enjoyed it and
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon